I'm a professional YouTuber, script
writer, and ginger with 6-7 years of
experience writing viral videos getting
millions of views. And today, I'll
reveal my secret five-step framework
that guarantees viral
Dude, what is this?
What? It's the hook. 95% retention. Keep
going. You're about to tell them about
the framework.
I
I don't have a framework. Yeah, don't
worry. That's why I put the most viral
scripting videos into ChatGPT. This is
literally what works. Just keep [music]
reading.
Hey,
do you want the views or not?
I think I want All right. to use my
brain.
Hey, that took me like 30 seconds to
generate.
Okay, let's try that again. This time,
no secret formulas, no manipulation
techniques, just how I actually write my
scripts.
The biggest mistake to make while
scripting a video is just opening a
blank page and scripting. No matter how
much you know about your topic, if you
start [music] writing without a plan,
you'll go all over the place. At least,
that's what usually happens for me. So,
before you write a single word, you got
to build a foundation starting with
Obviously, you got to have a solid idea
to begin with. It's a completely
separate video topic, so I'm not going
to dive deep into that here. Just find
something interesting for you and for
your audience. You can find it from
video comments, other YouTubers, Reddit
posts, or just have a spark while you're
on the toilet. I'm going to use this
video that you're watching as an example
to show you the entire process. So,
yeah, it's going to be a weird script.
Let's go.
Most people skip it and wonder why the
video feels off. So, what does that
mean? Well, why do the viewers click on
your video? And why are you making it?
For this tutorial, your goal is to,
well, learn how to write a viral script.
And my goal is to write a viral script
while teaching you how to write a viral
script. That's pretty aligned, right?
But let's take a random guru video. Your
goal is to learn how to make money, but
the guru's goal? Sell you their
overpriced course. They don't match.
>> [music]
>> That's why what they say feels fake. You
can sense it. Something's not right. You
just can't prove [music] it. So, if you
don't find your common goal with the
viewer, no matter how many fancy
storytelling techniques you [music] use,
the script's going to feel weird.
Now, the secret sauce for my scripts.
Every good script has a surface problem
[music] and a deeper problem. It's what
takes a script from a regular video to
your video. In my [music] case, sure,
I'm breaking down how I write scripts.
That's the surface. But what's the
deeper problem here? Well, let's not
give spoilers for now, but remember this
deeper problem concept for the end of
the video. Let's see if you can figure
it out before I say it. But if you've
watched my videos before, you might have
seen [music] the pattern. This video is
about making viral shorts, but the
deeper problem is about having patience.
This one, about editing cool videos.
Deeper problem, perfectionism. And this
is about me trying to have a shorts
channel. The deeper problem is having
[music] determination. It may seem
unnoticeable for a regular viewer, but
subconsciously, these are the things
that make your video stand out among
other videos. So, think about this for
your next video. Find the emotional
struggle underneath the technical
problem and write it down as well.
Never write the script without a
thumbnail. I mean, come on. It's common
knowledge at this point. Make a simple
draft in Canva or generate something
with AI. Just know what's the viewer's
first impression while clicking your
video. Because if your script doesn't
deliver on that promise, I mean, come
on, dude. It's over. It's over. And
packaging isn't only about thumbnails.
It's about every first impression, like
your domain name.
>> [music]
>> Let's say you've got a killer product,
made a great website, and then tell
people to check out your store, and you
drop a link that looks like this.
[music]
Whether you sell on Shopify,
Squarespace, or anywhere, you usually
get a weird random link like these. I
mean, some of these look like my YouTube
password. Wait, that's my password
screams unprofessional. [music] But if
you replace that mess with your
name.store, now we're talking. .store is
a domain name just like .com, but it's
built specifically for creators who sell
something online. It's clean, intuitive,
and it literally screams trust. .store
for your store. I mean, come on. It just
makes sense. I recently found out some
small creators like MrBeast, IShowSpeed,
[music]
Dude Perfect, another iZacman, and many
more people are already using .store as
their domain. And now,
I have one, too.
Thank you. Thank you. You can get my
[music] presets and guides from
IsaacVerse.store right now. It's
memorable, and it tells you exactly what
you're getting. And it's not just a
fancy name. .store domains are proven to
drive two times [music] the visibility.
Why? Because when people see the link,
they know it's a store straight away.
And when they know it's a store, they
click. When they click, they want They
want They add to cart. They add to cart.
Shh.
They buy. So, if you're a creator
selling merch, courses, art preset, or
literally anything, your .store domain
is waiting for you at the link [music]
in the description. Huge thanks to
.store for sponsoring this video.
Now, who are we actually writing this
script for?
It's not needed for every single video,
but it's good to have a document where
you write down one or two audience
[music] avatars who would watch your
channel. If you haven't heard this
before, it's pretty simple. Open a blank
document and write down as much detail
as you can about your potential viewer.
[music] For my case, it can be a
YouTuber with less than a thousand
subscribers who wants to write better
scripts for his video, knows the basics
about writing technique, retention, and
YouTube algorithm. Maybe struggling
[music] to get his first viral video.
The second avatar, someone more
intermediate, wants to learn something
new to apply in his next video, knows
more than average about scripting,
retention, analytics, and stuff. That's
probably the main audience I'm writing
for. Another small group, [music] and
maybe a guy who just likes watching
fancy edits and laughs at my terrible
jokes. So, which one are you? Every
channel has its own avatars. You can
write with more details, but I think
this is enough for a starting point.
Just know who you're writing for and
what's the complexity level you can go
without losing them.
Now, the next big step is to sit down
for a few hours and do some research
about the topic. I know what you're
thinking. I already know this stuff.
That's why I'm making the video. Yeah, I
thought that, too. But here's the thing.
Even if you think you already know
enough, there's always more to learn,
and it's a great moment to improve
yourself anyway. So, watch a few videos
on YouTube, read if there are any
sources you found online, ask AI some
questions, take note, write down what
they explained, and more importantly,
what they haven't explained. That gap,
that's your opportunity to shine.
[music] At the end of this part, you
have to have a bunch of random notes all
around the place. They may not make
sense yet, but it doesn't matter for
now.
>> [music]
>> You know the knowledge at this point,
but you need a clear structure to follow
while writing. What comes after what?
[music] How do the pieces fit together?
So, take a look at your notes, write
down all the points you want to explain,
and try to sequence them in a logical
direction. A tiny tweak I do here is to
clearly state where Isaac is at the
start of the video and where he will be
at the end. You can do that for
yourself, the explainer, or for the
viewer's point of [music] view. For
example, in my editing tutorial, the
start was Isaac wanting to make a
perfect editing tutorial. At the end, he
realizes it's about the process, not
perfection. See, a clear transformation.
That's what [music] we're aiming for.
Now, we've got the start and end points.
We've got the main problem and a deeper
problem. Here comes the interesting
part, taking them all and writing a
story to capture it. And how do we write
a story? Well, I made a whole video
about it, but here's the idea. There's a
simple framework that's been used since
>> [music]
>> forever. Harry Potter, How to Train Your
Dragon, Iron Man, King Arthur,
Gilgamesh. That's like 4,000 years ago.
Hero's journey. That's the name. The
story starts here. [music]
Then the hero gets a call to an
adventure. Then comes a wise man to help
the journey start. A lot of things
happen in between. A big crisis
approaches, gets a new Let me show you
how it actually [music] works in a
YouTube video. Have you watched my
editing tutorial? Cool, because if you
haven't, I'm about to spoil the entire
plot. Though, what kind of psycho
watches a tutorial for the story
anyways?
Well, when you say it like that, what
kind of psycho writes a story for a
tutorial? So, here it goes. Status quo,
that's where everything starts. Isaac
has a successful channel. Nothing's bad,
but something's off. Call to adventure,
something happens to kick [music] off
the story. It can be a problem, an
opportunity, a threat, or just a
curiosity. You know, the "Where's the
editing tutorial?" [music] comment.
Assistance, that's where the wise old
man comes in, Steven. Departure, that's
where the hero starts the journey,
[music] the actual tutorial begins.
Trials, that's the main part of the
YouTube video. All the points you want
to mention, the mistakes, some wins, and
maybe some losses, maps, breakdown,
[music] the whole thing. Approach,
remember the deeper problem? That's
where it appears. In the tutorial, the
perfectionism creeps in. Crisis,
everything goes sideways. This is the
lowest point of the story. 60 days pass,
[music] and Isaac is still editing the
same video. In good stories, though,
this is also where the identity change
happens. You got to show you don't know
everything. Don't be afraid to be
vulnerable, but no matter what, you got
to find a solution to the problem to
find the treasure. It's the reward. What
did you learn from that crisis moment?
Isaac realizes the escape from
perfectionism is to say, "It's good
enough." Result, hitting publish moment.
Return, the positive comments roll in.
New life, he's not the same person
[music] anymore. The mindset has
changed. Resolution, this is where all
the plot lines open up, and then status
quo again, and the cycle continues with
the next video. See, it works insanely
well for a YouTube video, but most
people still don't use it. So, the video
has no conflict, no stakes, and no
change at the end. Without that, it
would be just an editing tutorial with
some useful tips. But once you add the
story, it becomes a journey. And most
importantly, the viewer sees themselves
in you. That's how you build a loyal
audience. But it's not always that
simple. For reference, the hero's
journey map of this video looks
something like this.
I'll show the details once we actually
finish the journey, but it's quite
messy.
And finally, there's one more layer.
Okay, this one may be overkill for 90%
of channels out there, but I'm
explaining my entire process, and this
is a big part of it. So, here it goes.
Writing mini stories for your videos is
cool, but if you blindly use the hero's
journey, that's just a repeating cycle
with no ending. It works, but wouldn't
it be more epic if we connect all those
stories to one another? Use them as
pillars of a grand story that unfolds
with each video. You see where I'm going
with this? So, every video is connected.
The story scenes, the big charts, even
the reason I'm teaching you this, it's
all leading somewhere.
>> Dude, you're leaking the grand story.
They aren't supposed to know about the
prison yet. What? No, I'm just You
You're live?
Relax, man. They don't know what that
means.
Sorry, man. Can't take any risks.
>> What's that?
Well, I can't really reveal the grand
story of my videos since it's not
finished yet and I don't want to give
[music] spoilers, but you can understand
this concept by looking at the Marvel
movies. From Iron Man 1 in 2008, they
made stand-alone stories and combined
them all in a grand story that peaked
with Endgame in 2019.
>> [cheering]
>> Damn, the memories. What a time it was
to be human.
Just give me a moment.
>> [screaming]
>> Anyways,
once the plan is ready, I send [music]
it to my best friend and ask for his
opinion.
Oh,
I don't have a friend.
But, Chat GPT works. [music]
Now, you might ask it to write the
script for you based on your plan and
that's how you throw all your work in
the garbage
because it just writes a generic script
no matter how much [music] context you
give it. So, what I use it instead is
ask it to roast my outline. What did I
miss? Is it too boring? What can I add?
What can I remove? What about changing
the plot twist? After a few back and
forths, you're finally ready to
actually write the script. Open a blank
page, take your outline, set a timer,
and just type. Don't worry about the
grammar, wording, structure, [music] or
anything. Just get the thoughts out of
your head onto the page. Expand on each
point in your outline. The goal [music]
here is to have something to work with
instead of staring at a blank page. Here
are some small tactics I use while
writing.
Well, it's kind of common sense, but I
see so many people make this mistake.
They start breaking down really advanced
concepts right [music] at the beginning.
Of course, it makes you sound smart, but
most viewers don't really understand all
that and just leave the video. It's like
going from zero to a hundred right away.
So, start [music] by giving some context
for people who are not familiar with
what you're talking about. Then, explain
simple concepts and gradually increase
the complexity. Remember the start of
this video? We [music] were just talking
about the packaging, topic, research,
simple stuff, and we slowly increased to
stuff like hero's journey and universe
building. Now, YouTube advice says to
only explain [music] simple concepts and
avoid complex topics to maximize
retention. Yeah, that's indeed good for
retention, but it's not how I want to
cook. I want to give as much value as
possible to those who want to learn
more. I guess it's a fair trade to get
slightly lower retention in return.
You probably heard the rule show, don't
tell. [music] Well, everyone knows that.
I'm talking about something else and it
improves the retention way more if done
right. [music] Do you remember what I
said while explaining the deeper problem
concept? Sure, I'm breaking down how I
write scripts. But, what's the deeper
problem [music] here? Well, let's not
give spoilers for now, but remember this
deeper problem concept for the end of
the video. Let's see if you can figure
it out before I say it.
See what I did there? Instead of telling
you this is the deeper problem, I asked
you to figure it out by yourself. It
makes the video not just me talking, you
listening, but more like a conversation,
an interactive thing, and makes you pay
more attention. It's like two different
teachers. One just explains the lecture
from start to finish, but the other
doesn't reveal everything up front. He
gives you hints, asks you questions,
makes you think, and figure out the
answer by yourself.
And we all know how good it feels when
you actually figure out the answer,
right? It's the same principle here.
Lastly, not for the actual script, but
it makes your life way easier to add
some notes for editing. Things like
[music] add sigma grindset music, show a
footage of Captain America lifting
Mjolnir, or Isaac sending it to his best
friend via WhatsApp and match cut to
Chat GPT. Yeah, even that was scripted.
Keep writing until you've explained all
your bullet points, implemented the
hero's journey, and solved the deeper
problem that you've set up.
Once you finish the first draft, read
what you wrote, change up the order, add
some extra points, remove some
unnecessary stuff, and tweak [music] the
sentences to make them flow better. How
do you do that? Glad you asked.
Naturally, when you write, you write the
points like Okay, this happens, right?
And then, this happens.
>> But, it's too linear, too predictable,
boring. Instead, you should write like
This happens, but this happens,
therefore this happens. It's way more
interesting to listen to. At least the
writers of South Park say [music] so and
these guys made 28 seasons, so I think
they know what they're talking about. If
you paid attention, you may have caught
some points where I used that writing.
You know the knowledge at this point,
but you need a clear structure to follow
while writing. So, take a look at your
notes. Writing many stories for your
videos is cool, but if you blindly use
the hero's journey, that's just a
repeating cycle with no ending. It
works, but wouldn't it be more epic if
we connect all those stories to one
another? Of course, it makes you sound
smart, but most viewers don't really
understand all that and just leave the
video. So, start by giving some context
for people who are not familiar
>> makes everything more dynamic. Another
really weird tactic to make your script
more interesting is rhythm. Most
beginners write with the same sentence
length over and over again. It creates
[music] a monotone script, but if you
write your sentences with different
lengths, like the script of this video,
it makes [music] it less boring. I
actually learned this technique while
researching for this video, but realized
I've already been doing it
subconsciously in my script. So, it's a
nice tactic, but I don't think there's
any need to overthink it. Just make sure
not all your sentences are the same
length and you're good to go.
And lastly, send it to an AI and ask for
feedback or a friend if you have one.
So, what do you think?
Well, I mean, it's something. Something?
Look, it's not terrible, but it's too
complex. Hero's journey, universe
building, you got to think about
retention, dude. People will click off.
All right, I can refine it more.
>> Actually,
here. I ran it through the retention
optimizer AI. It removed those weird
parts that dropped your retention rate,
added some small [music] payoffs
throughout, and changed the ending to a
rage bait. Really? Yep, works every
time. It'll get at least 30% more watch
time. That's the goal, right?
Now, what do you think?
It It's better,
technically. And that's all that
matters. Just delete your version, use
this one, and the video goes viral. We
win.
Do it.
>> No. What?
It may have better retention, better
[music] everything,
but it doesn't have a soul, man.
I won't manipulate people to keep that
chart high and I won't delete actually
useful [music] parts just because they
hurt retention.
Sorry, man. I'm doing it my way.
Why do you always choose the long route?
Maybe you're not the right [music]
Isaac, either. What? Nothing.
But, the universe [music] building part
was badass, actually.
>> [music]
[music]